Jake: 看表了
Jake: Look at the watch.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice:坐后边玩手机
Alice: Sitting in the back playing on my phone.
Alice:感觉晕车了
Alice: I feel carsick.
Jake: 到了是吧
Jake: We arrived, right?
Jake: 确实到了
Jake: We really did arrive.
Jake:进去
Jake: Let's go in.
其他人：够荒凉的
Others: It's so desolate.
Jake: 咱也不知道这是啥地
Jake: We don't even know what place this is.
其他人：嗯信号不好
Others: Yeah, the signal is bad.
Jake: 皇家新村
Jake: Royal New Village.
其他人：信号不好啊
Others: The signal is bad, huh.
其他人：不走了呢
Others: Should we not go?
其他人：应该就这位置了100米
Others: This should be the place, about 100 meters.
Jake: 那行吧
Jake: Alright then.
其他人：是不就这
Others: Is this it?
Shure:  但不是这个
Shure: But it's not this one.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
其他人：不是再往前大铁门
Others: No, it's further ahead, the big iron gate.
Jake: 我我等会
Jake: Wait a minute.
Jake: 我我我这边看看
Jake: Let me check over here.
其他人：它不动了
Others: It's not moving.
Jake: 我这边也有地图可以看
Jake: I also have a map to check.
Alice:是65号
Alice: It's number 65.
Jake: 往前走往前走一会
Jake: Keep going, keep going a bit.
其他人：往前走
Others: Keep going.
其他人：信号不好
Others: The signal is bad.
Jake: 就这个就左边这个
Jake: It's this one, the one on the left.
Shure:  对这个口停就行
Shure: Yeah, stop at this entrance.
Jake: 两边都开吧
Jake: Open both sides.
其他人： 这边手动的啊
Others: This side is manual.
Katrina: 不太舒服
Katrina: Not feeling well.
Alice:我看手机了
Alice: I'm looking at my phone.
Alice:难受
Alice: Feeling sick.
Katrina:  服了待一个星期都不知道怎么走
Katrina: Staying here for a week, we still wouldn't know how to get around.
Katrina:  我猜是往这吧
Katrina: I guess it's this way.
Katrina:  对了应该这有紫藤花
Katrina: Right, there should be wisteria flowers here.
Alice:前
Alice: Forward.
Shure:  再往前是吗
Shure: Further ahead, right?
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Right?
Katrina:  是的这有一个
Katrina: Yes, here’s one.
Katrina: 右拐
Katrina: Turn right.
Shure:  左拐吗还是
Shure: Turn left or...
Katrina:  猜一下呗
Katrina: Just guess.
Alice:前
Alice: Forward.
Alice:还往前
Alice: Keep going forward.
Katrina:  真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure:  还往前不是的吧
Shure: Keep going forward? No way.
Tasha:  再往前
Tasha: Move forward.
Alice:还得往前
Alice: Keep going forward.
Tasha:  往前
Tasha: Forward.
Shure:  ah
Shure: Ah.
Katrina:  31右转
Katrina: Turn right at 31.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Shure:  可以啊
Shure: Got it.
Shure:  牛
Shure: Awesome.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my!
Shure:  勾人不记录
Shure: No one's keeping score.
Katrina:  勾人这脑子
Katrina: No one's brain is working.
Katrina:  这边不太行方向感
Katrina: The sense of direction here isn't great.
Shure:  好困
Shure: I'm so sleepy.
Katrina:  勾人不是万能的
Katrina: No one is perfect.
Shure:  我也不想整了
Shure: I don't want to do this anymore.
Shure:  想直接睡觉
Shure: I just want to sleep.
Katrina:  我也想睡觉了
Katrina: I want to sleep too.
Katrina:  我这还有两个会要开
Katrina: But I still have two more meetings.
Katrina:  呃
Katrina: Ugh.
Katrina:  能到时候他们先准备
Katrina: They can prepare in the meantime.
Katrina:  等会我来洗碗吧
Katrina: I’ll do the dishes later.
Katrina:  现在可能没啥空
Katrina: I might not have time now.
Katrina:  但现在应该要先腌
Katrina: But we should marinate first.
Katrina:  那个是不是
Katrina: Right?
Katrina:  910325 是不是
Katrina: Is it 910325?
Katrina:  我不记得啊
Katrina: I can't remember.
Alice:有个西瓜虫
Alice: There’s a pill bug.
Shure:  摁下那个星号
Shure: Press the star button.
Jake: 你家是刚刚有猫吗
Jake: Did you just get a cat?
Shure:  7多少多少人啊
Shure: How many people are there?
Lucia:  他刚才从那上面跑下来又跳下来
Lucia: It just ran down from there and jumped.
Alice:咪咪
Alice: Kitty.
Shure:  不是如果你摁对了
Shure: No, if you press it right
Shure:  他直接自己开
Shure: It will open by itself
Alice:咪咪
Alice: Mimi
Jake: 你你要先按一个键
Jake: You need to press a key first
Jake: 在在对你等到他
Jake: Yeah, you wait until it
Jake: 哔对
Jake: Beeps
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 牛啊牛啊
Jake: Awesome, awesome
Katrina:  310925
Katrina: 310925
Shure:  哦太牛了
Shure: Oh, amazing
Shure:  人类居然可以记住6位密码
Shure: Humans can remember a 6-digit code
Shure:  小心点那有那有
Shure: Watch out, watch out
Shure:  钉子好像
Shure: There's a nail, I think
Jake: 经过了3天的训练
Jake: After 3 days of training
Shure:  人类记住这串密码需要3天的训练
Shure: Humans need 3 days of training to remember this code
Shure:  AI 3秒用吗
Shure: AI can do it in 3 seconds
Katrina:  0.3
Katrina: 0.3
Jake: 三秒开玩笑
Jake: Three seconds? That's a joke
Shure:  3毫秒
Shure: 3 milliseconds
Shure:  小艾特他没有开灯
Shure: Little Ait, he didn't turn on the light
Jake: 3秒带开机吗
Jake: Does it take 3 seconds to boot up?
Shure:  开着呢
Shure: It's on
Jake: 三秒开机
Jake: Three seconds to start
Shure:  开灯吧
Shure: Turn on the light
Jake: 放冰箱放完冰箱就结束
Jake: Put it in the fridge, then it's done
Lucia:  我的留言板
Lucia: My message board
Lucia:  不是留言板
Lucia: Not the message board
Lucia:  就是那个软木的那个照片墙
Lucia: It's that cork photo wall thing
Katrina:  这个肉要腌吗
Katrina: Does this meat need to be marinated?
Katrina:  还是说先放冰箱
Katrina: Or should we put it in the fridge first?
Lucia:  这个东西
Lucia: This thing
Lucia:  它怎么这么大呀
Lucia: Why is it so big?
Lucia:  我以为它就一点点呢
Lucia: I thought it would be small
Lucia:  装起来就好
Lucia: Just pack it up
Katrina:  把肯德基扔了
Katrina: Throw away the KFC.
Shure:  我每天放冰箱的意义
Shure: What's the point of putting it in the fridge every day?
Shure:  就是留一天扔掉是吗
Shure: Just to keep it for a day and then throw it away?
Katrina:  扔了
Katrina: Throw it away.
Shure:  好饿好饿
Shure: So hungry, so hungry.
Shure:  好困好困好累好累
Shure: So sleepy, so sleepy, so tired, so tired.
Lucia:  哎这太夸张了
Lucia: Oh, this is too much.
Lucia:  算了一会再看他
Lucia: Forget it, let's check on him later.
Katrina:  我还买了个冰淇淋
Katrina: I also bought an ice cream.
Shure:  要都放了
Shure: Put everything in.
Katrina:  鸡蛋呢
Katrina: What about the eggs?
Katrina:  扔了
Katrina: Throw them away.
Shure:  放放放
Shure: Put them in, put them in.
Lucia:  前两天买的那个
Lucia: The ones we bought a couple of days ago.
Lucia:  可以先拿出来了今天晚上把它吃了
Lucia: We can take them out and eat them tonight.
Shure:  导完
Shure: After that...
Lucia:  然后把新的再补充进去
Lucia: Then we can replenish with new ones.
Lucia:  哦不是这个这个
Lucia: Oh, not this one, this one.
Shure:  导完就
Shure: After that...
Lucia:  再不吃可能坏了
Lucia: If we don't eat it soon, it might spoil.
Lucia:  放到这吧
Lucia: Put it here.
Shure:  为什么他要听RMB
Shure: Why does he have to listen to RMB?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Lucia:  调料
Lucia: The seasoning.
Shure:  这个小狗
Shure: This little dog.
Jake: RNB
Jake: RNB.
Jake: 放芒果是吧芒果拿出来
Jake: Put the mango in, right? Take the mango out.
Lucia:  哦对芒果
Lucia: Oh, right, the mango.
Jake: 芒果放这
Jake: Put the mango here.
Shure:  不用不用
Shure: No need, no need.
Shure:  电子版扫描就行
Shure: Just do an electronic scan.
Jake: 放不了等一下
Jake: It won't fit, wait a second.
Katrina:  没拿出吃了吧
Katrina: Didn't you take it out to eat?
Katrina:  这几个
Katrina: These few.
Lucia:  我们晚上可以把
Lucia: We can eat them tonight.
Katrina:  这4个吃了吧占位置
Katrina: Let's eat these four, they're taking up space.
Lucia:  让我们那啥
Lucia: So we can...
Lucia:  做那些甜品的时候需不需要用
Lucia: Do we need them for making those desserts?
Jake: 今晚做什么呀
Jake: What are we making tonight?
Katrina:  对这个吗
Katrina: This one, right?
Tasha:  都可以
Tasha: Anything is fine.
Lucia:  就草莓和芒果
Lucia: Just strawberries and mangoes.
Lucia:  好像微微之前说做甜点用
Lucia: I think Tasha mentioned using them for desserts before.
Lucia:  可以先放一下
Lucia: We can set them aside for now.
Lucia:  然后如果用不着了再把它吃掉
Lucia: And if we don't need them, we can eat them later.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Katrina: 行我放二楼去
Katrina: Okay, I'll put it on the second floor.
Jake: 热量爆炸是吧
Jake: It's gonna be a calorie bomb, right?
Lucia:  芒果
Lucia: Mango.
Lucia:  怎么给我一种好像要尽快吃它的感觉
Lucia: It feels like we need to eat it soon.
Jake: 今天就吃
Jake: Let's eat it today.
Lucia:  再放可能就
Lucia: If we leave it longer, it might...
Tasha:  那就今天就吃
Tasha: Then let's eat it today.
Jake: 今天今天围绕着他能做什么
Jake: Let's see what we can make with it today.
Katrina:  我的ice cream
Katrina: My ice cream...
Lucia:  对会今天把它做了
Lucia: Yes, let's make it today.
Jake: 对今天围绕着他
Jake: Yes, today, we'll focus on it.
Shure:  我我们我可以
Shure: We, we can...
Shure:  我们可以养小芒狗
Shure: We can raise a little mango dog.
Lucia:  养小芒狗
Lucia: Raise a little mango dog.
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 哈哈哈芒果核这个我知道
Jake: Hahaha, I know about the mango seed.
Shure:  哈哈哈知道那个吗
Shure: Haha, do you know about that?
Alice:就那个芒果盒
Alice: The mango seed.
Tasha:  芒果皮芒果狗是吧嗯
Tasha: Mango skin, mango dog, right?
Shure:  芒果核对
Shure: Mango seed, yes.
Lucia:  哦没反应过来
Lucia: Oh, I didn't get it at first.
Alice:让他把它嗦嗦嗦
Alice: Let it lick, lick, lick.
Lucia:  哎我鞋带没有开
Lucia: Oh, my shoelace isn't untied.
Shure:  对嗦嗦干净点
Shure: Yes, lick it clean.
Katrina:  你住一楼是吧
Katrina: You live on the first floor, right?
Katrina:  那直接放一楼呗
Katrina: Then just put it on the first floor.
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Alice:这个放冰箱
Alice: Put this in the fridge.
Lucia:  芒果核
Lucia: Mango seed.
Katrina:  对放一楼冰箱
Katrina: Yes, put it in the fridge on the first floor.
Katrina:  因为他那个可能
Katrina: Because it might...
Shure:  工作量爆棚了有点
Shure: The workload might be too much.
Jake: 养芒果要工序很多吗
Jake: Does raising mangoes require a lot of work?
Lucia:  用就一直搁那吸那个芒果盒就行了
Lucia: Just keep it there and let it suck on the mango seed.
Jake: 一直吃是吧
Jake: Keep eating, right?
Shure:  嗦干净一点就好
Shure: Just make sure to clean it well.
Lucia:  然后洗一洗
Lucia: And then wash it.
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure:  就是迷惑行为
Shure: It's just confusing behavior.
Jake: 迷惑行为是吧不知道
Jake: Confusing behavior, huh? Don't know.
Shure:  多干净对
Shure: How clean, yeah.
Shure:  人类为什么会把一个植物的种子
Shure: Why do humans treat a plant's seed
Shure:  当成一个宠物
Shure: as a pet?
Katrina:  面包要放冰箱吗
Katrina: Should we put the bread in the fridge?
Shure:  不然的话大家那吃吃上就得饿死了
Shure: Otherwise, everyone will starve while eating.
Lucia:  面包要不咱们拿到楼上去放楼上冰箱
Lucia: Why don't we take the bread upstairs to the fridge?
Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia:  我看还有啥要放的
Lucia: I'll see what else needs to go in.
Lucia:  菜就不放了吧
Lucia: Let's not put the vegetables in.
Jake:等会吧他们已经关了没关系
Jake: Wait a bit, they already closed, it's fine.
Shure: 我先把我的去导上
Shure: I'll go ahead and load mine first.
Lucia:  这个也得放冰箱
Lucia: This also needs to go in the fridge.
Lucia:  榴莲这个也要放冰箱吧
Lucia: This durian also needs to go in the fridge, right?
Katrina:  放一楼冰箱吧
Katrina: Put it in the first-floor fridge.
Lucia:  冷冻
Lucia: Freeze it.
Lucia:  冷冻的话就放一
Lucia: If freezing, just put it
Lucia:  楼冰箱就可以了
Lucia: in the first-floor fridge.
Alice:这榴莲是准备烤着吃还是怎样的
Alice: Are we planning to bake this durian or what?
Katrina:  这好像放不下这列了都
Katrina: It seems like it can't fit in this row.
Lucia: 那就别放太多别万一对
Lucia: Then don't put too much, in case...
Katrina:  不能再放那个酒
Katrina: Can't fit the wine either.
Lucia: 着放这好了先
Lucia: Just put it here for now.
Katrina:  放这
Katrina: Put it here.
Lucia:  咱今天晚上反正要喝一瓶酒对吧
Lucia: We're going to drink a bottle of wine tonight anyway, right?
Lucia:  晚上是喝哪瓶
Lucia: Which bottle are we drinking tonight?
Katrina:  喝气泡酒吧
Katrina: Let's drink the sparkling wine.
Lucia:  喝是喝这个吗
Lucia: Are we drinking this one?
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Sure.
Lucia:  是喝粉红这个好像因为这是今天新买的
Lucia: We're drinking the pink one, since we just bought it today.
Lucia:  能放下不
Lucia: Can it fit?
Katrina:  我感觉它害怕
Katrina: I feel like it's scared.
Lucia:  要不这样把它横放到这里面
Lucia: How about this, let's lay it horizontally in here.
Lucia:  小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Katrina:  这个要放进来码
Katrina: Should we put this one in?
Lucia:  放着也行然后咱喝时候再拿出去
Lucia: We can leave it there and just take it out when we drink.
Lucia:  好像没啥了是吧
Lucia: Seems like that's it, right?
Lucia:  很完美
Lucia: Very perfect.
Lucia:  哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Oh my goodness.
Lucia:  为什么关不上
Lucia: Why won't it close?
Lucia:  关是能关上就是拿什么稍微有点挤
Lucia: It can close, but it's a bit tight with something inside.
Lucia: 没事不管它
Lucia: It's okay, just leave it.
Katrina: 哪呀什么东西夹住了
Katrina: Where? What's stuck?
Lucia:  对可能有啥放的比较满
Lucia: Yeah, maybe it's just too full.
Lucia:  算了用点劲关就行
Lucia: Never mind, just use a bit of force to close it.
Katrina:  你的糖微微
Katrina: Your sugar, Tasha.
Katrina:  微微
Katrina: Tasha.
Tasha: 哦谢谢
Tasha: Oh, thanks.
Lucia:  我们现在可以停了
Lucia: We can stop now.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Lucia:  我们现在可以停了
Lucia: We can stop now.
Tasha: 都停了
Tasha: Everything's stopped.
Jake: 停停停停了吧
Jake: Stop, stop, stop, right?
Katrina: OK已经收拾好了冰箱
Katrina: Okay, the fridge is all sorted.
Jake: 对停了对休息时间不得工作
Jake: Yes, stop. No work during break time.
Lucia:  休息时间不得工作
Lucia: No work during break time.
Tasha: 现在开始休息了是吧
Tasha: So we're on break now?
Jake: 对休息休息不得工作对
Jake: Yes, break time, no work.
Lucia:  好我就喜欢这样的leader
Lucia: Great, I love this kind of leader.
Jake: 好好不用这个线给我就好
Jake: Okay, okay, don't need this cable, just give it to me.
Shure: 我就是每天利用休息时间然后去工作
Shure: I just use my break time every day to work.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 哎这个S1
Jake: Hey, this S1.
Jake: 你还你还没有关
Jake: You still haven't closed it.
Shure: 然后先先把碳买上吧
Shure: Then let's buy some coal first.
Katrina: 要关吗
Katrina: Should I close it?
Jake: 对要关一下 complete
Jake: Yes, you need to close it.
Katrina: 那我complete呗
Katrina: So I'll complete it?
Jake: 呃对你没按complete
Jake: Uh, yes, you haven't pressed complete.
Katrina: 我的线在桌上吗
Katrina: Is my cable on the table?
Jake: 在
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 你complete了吗
Jake: Did you complete it?
Jake: ok ok 还在闪
Jake: Okay, okay, it's still flashing.